Hey youtubers, it's Charlie! This is going
to be my Walking Dead Episode 7 video. They
did all of the things! Very big spoiler warning
in case you haven't seen the episode yet.
So here we go! There is a new round of the
giveaway all you have to do to enter is be
a subscriber and leave a comment on this video
she's a $20 Amazon gift card so if you guys
and see top five WTF let's just go ahead and
start with number five Glenn is alive the
open the episode with them they totally pulled
the bait and switch thing even if you didn't
see spoiler behind-the-scenes stuff you probably
guessed that there was some way the Glenn
was going to survive it was a great way to
open the episode mean it was a great scene
especially when heated throws the ball down
like a stupid I said catch but I feel like
the reveal would've worked a lot better if
there hadn't been any behind-the-scenes spoil
re-images that it posted on the Internet or
if they hadn't taken him out of the opening
credits and even bigger than that he didn't
go on talking dead the night that he supposedly
died that's the biggest thing of all like
usually actors when they die will go on talking
dead be like hey yeah I'm really sad that
I had the die is so funny stories about how
the show runners told them hey look were going
to be killing you next week so I kind of feel
like this was a no-win situation for The Walking
Dead producers like there was no way people
were not can you see him walking around on
the set so whatever I give him pass at least
they tried I mean this is not the greatest
plot twists that they've ever gone for but
I think one of the reasons they swung for
the fences with this is because this whole
first half of the season is taking place within
the span of like a single week almost because
they can't push forward too much in time they
can introduce too many things they have to
create drama within the group with like Maggie
is pregnant she's can have a baby but we don't
know cleanse alive is the baby going to grow
up without a dad what's going on anyone who's
been criticizing this first half of the season
for being too much like season two of Herschel's
far you're not super far-off I'd I do think
it's better now than it was then I just hope
that they don't overstay their welcome and
onto my number four WTF Carol finds out that
Morgan is hiding someone in a secret basement
really all of Morgan scenes were by him facing
the Jedi Council's justice you can speculate
on which one's Carol which ones michonne which
ones Rick I think we all feel like they are
in the right for taking him to task for not
killing the wolves that ended up almost killing
Rick it's not just that they almost killed
breakage that they also lost that car they
could have used that car to leave the walkers
away speed which we don't know what's can
happen in that basement now the Carol knows
that the Wolf is there it's almost like were
going back to prison Carol where she killed
Karen because she thought she was going to
turn if there's a chance that she could go
down Carol will go into Terminator mode and
just take care of it going will keep you from
turning into a monster is killing that was
such a great way to answer Sam so dark just
so dark but on my number three WTF Glen and
eat it they make a big repair just because
Enid is so funny and Glenn is so determined
yelling at the talk Glenn Glenn just having
to take all of her should is just practice
for whenever Glenn's child is that age I should
actually say that the bigger surprise for
me is that Enid is still on the show I thought
that she left completely and she is a little
bit more fun with Glenn right now that she
was with Carl on my number two WTF though
miniport stick versus car all looks like it's
going to go down at least that's what they
want us to think but because of the Glenn
bait and switch I'm just expecting it to go
down some other way for those of you that
have not read the comics it seems like there
teasing a very big plot twist that happens
to Carl's character but because it would be
super spoiler he if you do want to talk about
it you have read the comics just please use
spoiler tag's I think given the way the TV
show has treated storylines in the past 50-50
odds that miniport stick will go after Carl
with the gun the other side of that being
that he'll try to save Carl it just it seems
too obvious that they want you to think that
he's going after Carl with the gun yet he's
super creepy he's super gun happy so he's
definitely get a costume sort of accident
when it comes to The Walking Dead they are
very misleading just just look at what happened
with Glenn so do not take the bait right away
but I mean there's still a chance he could
try to shoot Carl in of course on my number
one WTF the tower comes down leaving a point
of entry for the super horde and it becomes
no way out so that is basically where we are
in the comics for those that are asking the
story arc that the TV shows doing right now
is no way out walkers get in she goes down
a bunch of people end up dying like it definitely
bins out the cast of because it is kind of
spoil re-like the characters that end up dying
or just a one more time please use spoiler
tag's if you want to talk about comic book
storyline specifically but because next week
is the midseason finale on walking dead there
will definitely be characters dying there
there is not been a midseason finale in recent
memory where no one has died the real question
is is like how many of the save zone people
like the new characters begin to kill off
compared to pre-existing main characters they
totally just saved Glenn so I think that he
save but I'm actually curious to see if they
kill off Morgan just as is a way of showing
how there are consequences to not killing
people he is continually been confronted with
that idea of life is precious but some people
do not deserve to live they burn people Morgan
so obviously this wolf who is like very clearly
bent on killing every single man woman and
child in the save zone is gonna do something
terrible and I'm wondering if in the chaos
of the super horde getting in Morgan is going
to go down let me know in the comments below
what do you guys think is going to die midseason
finale main cast and supporting characters
like new save zone characters when it's all
said and done I felt like it was a great episode
I did not like the Glenn twist I meet is total
bait and switch game of thrones is doing the
exact same thing with Jon Snow but they did
the smart thing it did it with their season
finale I feel like that's acceptable words
like all man were not can have black and find
out if he still alive because they will start
filming for another six months so is not like
there were spoiler he images of him walking
around the set within a couple weeks but that
did happen with Glenn's would like wait a
minute why is he walking around onset we just
saw him die so that was a great idea on the
show's part to try that I just I feel like
it didn't go over as well as they'd hoped
but the really fun thing that we need to remember
is that they did not answer the question who
radioed for help to Daryl Knapp Abraham Daryl
Sasha still on their way back to the save
zone so we see they're going to arrive in
the midseason finale the maybe they'll run
afoul that new group again who I do think
are the saviors from the comics they really
only announced the knee can casting a little
while ago so I think it's a little too soon
to expect him and episodes I'm not expecting
him to like the latter part of the season
speaking of time delay in episode like you
were watching episodes now for the party filter
like the next 45 episodes terror right now
as were seeing her is still super pregnant
because the actor's in real life is pregnant
for right now the day I'm posting this video
she's already had the baby so she's like she's
back to normal so that seems like Tara has
been sneaking a lot of food out of the pantry
it just because she's pregnant in real life
in related news I will say congratulations
to last week's giveaway winner Blake Scherer
please private message me on the back and
my channels and get your contact info was
can happen tomorrow is I have a new game of
thrones to post a new Jessica Jones if you
guys haven't been watching that it is awesome
you need to check it out if for those of you
that have been asking about into the Badlands
I'm not intending to do videos for that but
it is a really good-looking series they did
The Walking Dead fear The Walking Dead thing
where they give it six episodes and then they
either decide to pick it up for season two
or cancel it forever and it seems like it's
doing pretty well so I think you'll get the
season two but it's it's a fun show to white
as way for everything to post you can click
here for all my walking dead season six videos
and you can click here for the Star Wars teaser
that I just posted whole bunch of Maz Kanata
and there's actually a game of thrones actress
I think you might spot someone that's part
of the Rogue squadron. thank you so much for
watching, everybody let's high five and I'll
see you guys tonight!